cet incident rare lors d'une visite
présidentielle à agen nicolas sarkozy a
été violemment prise à partie lors d'un
bain de foule
l'homme a été interpellé valérie astruc
régis masini c'est un bain de foule
comme il en prend deux fois par semaine
autour du président ses gardes du corps
devant lui une centaine de badauds
c'est alors qu'une magret violemment
l'épaule du président immédiatement
l'auteur de l'agression est plaqué au
sol par les forces de sécurité c'était
violent
c'est un grand gars costauds et de
l'affairé lamelles 48 concerts il était
très agressive parce qu'il a quand même
bousculé à l'épaule dans depuis derrière
les barrières et il avait la notation du
donner un coup je pense avec l'autre
bras sur le moment le président se
baissent comme s'il voulait éviter un
coup mais quelques secondes plus tard il
reprend son bain de foule avec calme
pas de commentaire c'est pourtant la
première fois que le président est
physiquement pris à partie la lune une
très bonne réaction j'ai à dire c'est
presque un cas d'école c'est quelque
chose qui va nous servir nous en
formation parce que vous avez une
agression et vous avez une réaction qui
est immédiate
l'agresseur est un homme de 32 ans
jusque là inconnu des services de police
il voulait interpeller le président sur
l'intervention de la france en libye
actuellement en garde à vue il encourt
trois ans de prison et 45000 euros
d'amendé
le président quant à lui n'a pas
l'intention de porter plainte
[Musique]